four boys at a Melbourne private school
have been suspended for ranking their female classmates appearances
and using proof that spending $30,000 a year on your son's education
is not gonna ensure that he doesn't go and ðŸ‡ somebody
so people are always on at me about like
why do you talk about sexist language
like this doesn't actually matter
like all of that type of thing
and this is some evidence
these year 11 student boys were ranking the girls in their class on a scale
a scale from wifey to unwrapable
you know how I often talk about the way that um
patriarchy and many men like to categorise women into like
down towards God's place
Madonna or wife or good woman
bad woman well um
to these guys credit
they've actually created more of a spectrum approach from wifey to cutie
to objects to get out to un ðŸ‡ able
these boys are 17 and they're not only using the word ðŸ‡
they're describing women as whether they would enact ðŸ‡ on them or not
and if you think that this doesn't actually lead to actual sexual assault
then you are much mistaken
this is exactly the type of language that normalises sa as a joke
a light hearted thing or something that you're entitled to as a man
and in a society where it's normalised or culture where it's normalised
it happens for those of you who say oh
objectification that doesn't happen
they literally are describing women as object
there is an Excel spreadsheet with the word object in it
and they're literally describing girls
I shouldn't say women these are girls as objects
get out as an interesting one too
I mean it's just like you're not worth it because you're not hot enough
I don't want you in my line of vision
you don't deserve to be here at school
get out of my sight and then the wifey one is interesting
it's like this woman is wife material
so I hate that term I hate this type of categorisation of women
it completely supports and props up ðŸ‡ culture
and it completely undermines consent and respect
and this is the type of culture that we're talking about
that starts at a really young age
that leads to sv becoming normalised accepted
tolerated in society by everyone